James is interested in weather
conditions and weather the downtown
train he sometimes takes runs on time
for a year James records weather each
day is sunny cloudy rainy or snowy as
well as weather this train arrives on
time or is delayed his results are
displayed in the table below alright
this is interesting these columns on
time delayed and the total so for
example when it was sunny there's a
total of 170 sunny days that year 167 of
which the train was on time three of
which the train was delayed and we could
look at that by the different types of
weather conditions and then they say for
these days are the events delayed and
snowy independent so to think about this
and remember we're only going to be able
to figure out experimental probabilities
and you should always view experimental
probabilities it somewhat suspect the
more experiments you're able to take the
more likely it is to approximate the
true theoretical probability but there's
always some chance that they might be
different or even quite different let's
use this data to try to calculate the
experimental probability so the key
question here is what is the probability
that the train is delayed and then we
want to think about what is the
probability that the train is delayed
given that it is snowy if we knew the
theoretical probabilities and if they
were exactly the same if the probability
of being delayed was exactly the same as
the probability of being delayed given
snowy then being delayed or being snowy
would be independent but if we knew the
theoretical probabilities and the
probability of being delayed given snowy
were different than the probability of
being delayed then we would not say that
these are independent variables now we
don't know the theoretical probabilities
we're just going to calculate the
experimental probabilities and we do
have a good number of experiments here
so if these are quite different I would
feel confident saying that they are
dependent if they are pretty close with
the experimental probability I would say
that it would be hard to make the
statement that
they are dependent and that you would
probably lean towards independence but
let's calculate this what is the
probability that the train is just
delayed pause this video and try to
figure that out
well let's see if we just think in
general we have a total of 365 trials or
365 experiments and of them the train
was delayed 35 times now what's the
probability that the Train is delayed
given that it is Snowie pause the video
and try to figure that out well let's
see we have a total of 20 snowy days and
we are delayed 12 of those 20 snowy days
and so this is going to be a probability
12 20th is the same thing as if we
multiply both the numerator and the
denominator by 5 this is a 60%
probability or I could say a 0.6
probability of being delayed when it is
snowy this is of course in experimental
probability which is much higher than
this
this is less than 10% right over here
this right over here is less than 0.1 I
could get a calculator to calculate it
exactly it'll be 9 point something
percent or 0.9 something but clearly
this you are much more likely at least
from the experimental data it seems like
you know a much higher proportion of
your snowy days are delayed than just
general days in general than just
general days and so based on this data
because the experimental probability of
being delayed given snowy is so much
higher than the experimental probability
of just being delayed I would make the
statement that these are not independent
so for these days are the events delayed
and snowy independent no